es un ritual muy eficaz en tübingen en
el suroeste de alemania la cruz roja se
instala todos los días a las 4 de la
tarde en la plaza del mercado para
realizar una sesión gratuita de pruebas
de covite supervisada por la médica de
urgencia lisa peder las personas llegan
ahora aquí les damos el número se
registra su nombre y luego se dirigen a
la parte de atrás para la prueba la
iniciativa fue presentada a finales de
noviembre por la presidenta voluntaria
de la cruz roja con el objetivo de
permitir que las familias se reunieran
durante las fiestas de fin de año sin
temor a contagiarse
desde entonces 700 personas se realizan
las pruebas cada semana en una ciudad
que tiene alrededor de 89 mil habitantes
me hice la prueba antes de navidad' y
esta es la segunda vez me parece que
tranquiliza mucho mi fosa tiene una
enfermedad pulmonar y mi hija es
educadora me siento cansado desde ayer y
no quiero ponerlas en riesgo
el resultado es anunciado al cabo de 10
minutos es negativo para el 90% de los
casos
es muy sencillo cuando se hacen pruebas
como aquí hay alrededor de un 1% de
personas contagiadas
ese porcentaje entra de inmediato en
cuarentena y eso evita por supuesto más
contagios
bayamo sentaban que en esta realización
masiva de pruebas es uno de los
elementos de la estrategia implementada
en tübingen para reforzar la protección
de los adultos mayores y de la población
en riesgo
aquí los residentes y los visitantes de
las residencias para adultos mayores se
realizan pruebas una vez a la semana los
mayores de 65 años reciben de manera
gratuita mascarillas ffp2 desde
noviembre la municipalidad le recomienda
a los habitantes más jóvenes que eviten
ir a los supermercados en la mañana para
permitirle a los mayores como andreas
hacer su compra
los horarios incluso están reservados en
los almacenes para los mayores de 80
años y yo tengo 88 además la ciudad se
encargó de que tengamos estas
mascarillas
efe efe
de dos más
a los pensionados también se les pide
que eviten los transportes públicos
cuentan con un servicio de transporte
particular por el precio de un tiquete
de bus
esta encarna y mensual para el
transporte público me permite utilizar
este taxi filtros adicional hoy
elizabeth fuse fue al dentista utiliza
el taxi para adultos mayores dos veces a
la semana después de haber perdido una
amiga al principio de la pandemia ya no
quiere utilizar el transporte público
fue realmente terrible para todos
nosotros además porque estamos
convencidos de que se contagió en el bus
y no le gustaba mucho expresarse en
transporte en fría firme los taxis para
adultos mayores se realizaron 12 mil
trayectos en 2020
enrico es estudiante y dedica dos días a
la semana a manejar uno de estos taxis
es un trabajo genial y además se tiene
la sensación de estar contribuyendo
desde donde podemos a la seguridad
general durante la pandemia aunque por
un tiempo fue criticada y considerada
como una discriminación frente a los
adultos mayores la estrategia de
tübingen contra el hobbit ahora muestra
sus resultados desde el comienzo del año
alrededor de 20 personas mayores de 75
años se han contagiado pero la tasa de
incidencia en la municipalidad es dos
veces menor
que
el resto de la región les traje siete
equipos para la toma de muestras y son
todavía más sencillos de usar estos
bomberos de una circunscripción vecina
también se preparan para montar un
centro de realización de pruebas
gratuito a lista federal él le gustaría
que todo el país lo hiciera
nuestra estrategia finalmente está dando
de qué hablar y de hecho recibo muchas
llamadas de alcaldes de consejeros
municipales que quieren hacer lo mismo
que nosotros y que me piden que les
provea pruebas y que les expliquen
nuestra estrategia en realidad estoy
haciendo el trabajo de las autoridades
sanitarias pero no puedo encargarme de
esto yo sola especialmente porque estas
medidas le han costado tan solo 500 mil
euros a la ciudad para boris palmer
el alcalde ecologista de tübingen el
cálculo es sencillo ahora milita por
detener los confinamientos repeticiones
lo que me preocupa es que en europa
todavía tenemos un número de contagios
muy elevado y nuestra única solución es
el confinamiento un método medieval que
evita todo contacto entre las personas
es absolutamente necesario encontrar una
estrategia que proteja ante todo a las
poblaciones
en riesgo porque no podemos seguir así
también necesitamos una estrategia de
seguimiento como en asia que nos permite
detectar este virus con las nuevas
tecnologías mientras la campaña de
vacunación alemana contra el jove 19 se
atrasa el cordón sanitario alrededor de
las poblaciones en riesgo y la
realización masiva de pruebas continúan
en tübingen la ciudad acaba de
desbloquear cien mil euros para realizar
las pruebas a los estudiantes de colegio
dos veces a la semana